as long as the shooting's being taking
place and people being killed and
wounded throughout our community i can
never claim
success but we do be more effective and
we i think that we're an effective group
[Music]
hello everybody my name is pastor corey
brooks and you got it i'm still here 100
days november the 20th of february 28th
living on this rooftop in this tent
right behind me
every now and then i have the
opportunity to come to you from o block
the block that we call opportunity block
named after a young man named od perry
who was shot and killed the gangs picked
up his name
and started calling it o block we
decided we're going to keep the o but
we're going to call it opportunity block
so thank you for joining me
on my rooftop revelations thank you to
fox for allowing me to come
to you and speak to you about different
ideas subjects
things that i have on my mind when i
wake up
this day i woke up and i was thinking
about
gang retaliation so i called one of our
violence prevention leaders our director
james high smith
and i wanted him to talk with us today
just about that issue
retaliation
so welcome brother hai smith
james hassmith is our violence
prevention director he oversees our
staff and real quick i just want to jump
in
why is it important that we have a
violence
interruption team a violence
intervention team
when it comes to retaliation
well
one of the most uh deadly parts about
the
[Music]
because when you come back come to down
to rep uh retaliation
it's anybody it's not the thing that
they just going at one person the way
things are today they go at the whole
block if you live on that block then
they shooting at you so what we have to
do is we have to get down and step into
it as soon as it happens
and this is why we try to be there
when when the emotions is running high
when everybody is talking about
concerned about it and so upset about it
we want to be there to be a a voice of
reason
yeah i know the other night um there was
a shooting and we talked and you sent
some of the workers over to the hospital
why do you why do you do things like
that why send them over to the hospital
because that is the peak of it all
everyone there is emotionally charged
and what we do is it's more not so that
we intervene in what we're doing is
observing
we're recognizing who exactly who is the
most hot-headed who is the most one that
we can look out and figure out and
single out as one of the calm he is the
ones who can we can talk to to use as a
as a bridge so to speak to get inside
and try to talk to these justices to try
to avert
uh retaliation
yeah do you think um last question do
you do you think we're being successful
here project good and why is that
well i think that
if uh
i can't claim success
as long as the shooting's been taking
place people being killed and wounded
throughout our community i can never
claim
success but we do be more effective and
we i think that we're an effective group
because we do have a say in the group we
have a place to start keeping a pulse on
what's going on and being able to
address address the situation
close up and in person yeah well i
appreciate you man i appreciate what
you're doing i appreciate your
leadership uh thank you for how you're
leading our violence team and and making
sure that we
calm the violence as much as possible
here on the south side of chicago in the
woodlawn area
and uh it's it's a it's an awesome team
and so thank you for doing all the work
that you do listen we appreciate the
work of our violence prevention team
here at project hood you want to find
out more about it you can go to
projecthood.org
projecthood.org and you can find out
more about our violence prevention team
and how they try to stop retaliation and
make sure that they mediate conflicts
that's what they do best so until
tomorrow as i always say
peace
you